Ron DeSantis
may not be a
presidential candidate yet,
but the Florida governor
is expected to make a decision
when his state's
legislative session ends in May.
Still, that is not stopping Donald Trump
from treating him
like a top rival
and maligning his acolyte turned enemy.
The latest dig
slamming DeSantis,
his foreign policy credentials
after his criticism of Vladimir Putin.
This kind of neocon
rhetoric mocking
Russia's nuclear weapons,
along with implying
that Putin must be tried
in presumably executed as a war criminal,
only increases
the chance of deadly nuclear escalation.
We need a statesman
and a peacemaker in the White House,
not someone who recites
mindless and recycled
talking points
to win the approval of the failed
foreign policy establishment.
Our panel is back with us.
And Trump is
going after dissenters from the far, far
right here.
But I just want to play this real quick.
This is from Hannity,
his interview
with Hannity, where he talks about his,
I guess, his friend Vladimir Putin,
Putin
Well, I'm going to
have to go a little short, but
I got along with him.
Great.
Had I been president, he would have been
much better off
because he wouldn't
have gone into Ukraine.
But ultimately, he's
going to take over all of Ukraine
sounding there like
he is ready to throw in the towel
on all of Ukraine.
That will also be a problem, too.
But DeSantis is
dealing with the issue of the flip flop
being tough on Ukraine at first,
then backtracking
That's going to get him.
And this is why the Sanders
has a tougher race to run, right?
Because he has to
not only try an appeal to the Trump base,
which was his initial comments
about Russia and Ukraine,
talking about calling it
a territorial dispute,
but then he also has to listen
to some of the criticism
that he's getting from
establishment Republicans
who want him to have
a more mainstream position on on Ukraine.
Now, when you see Trump,
they're saying that Putin's
going to take over Ukraine.
I guess that's
how he's going to avert World War three.
Is this allow Putin to take over Ukraine?
Because that's what he said
in his criticism of the sands
and saying
that he is the only one
who can prevent World
War Three and bring about peace.
Again, something tells me that
that's going to be an issue
that DeSantis is also trying to
I mean, he's the governor of Florida.
He has to burnish his
foreign policy credentials.
Yeah.
And I mean, there are places in which
I think he has really kind of staked
stake out ground.
Right.
Like he
he has called for
being really tough on China.
He's reportedly
planning a trip to Israel,
I believe, next month. Right.
And he's taken former trips to Israel
and I think
there are places in which he feels like
he can take really a tough stance,
I think, on the Ukraine issue.
I mean, he was trying to navigate this
fine line.
Polling shows that some Americans
are concerned
about kind of endless
spending in Ukraine.
I think the challenge for this,
your point is like
there's not a lot of wiggle room
for nuance on that issue
within the Republican electorate.
So this has been, what,
pretty clearly
a tough couple of weeks for DeSantis.
And it's a time
when he's been playing to friendly media
rolling out a book tour.
I look at the polls, the Fox poll today,
just the latest showing
Trump growing in his lead
against DeSantis.
30 points
now compared to 15 points
ahead in February.
Yeah,
that's the big problem for DeSantis
because he's kind of
putting out this trial balloon
kind of in the race
but not officially in the race.
And things aren't looking good
and he's not getting the foothold
that he thought he would
get as the alternative
to former
President Trump in the risk is right now,
he's still staffing
up, he's still raising money.
But if he can't show that he can be
that viable
Trump alternative,
then we could see that start to diminish.
And he
he might not ever officially
become a candidate for president.
He is dealing with the fact
that he's not a candidate,
but Trump is attacking him
like a candidate.
He's become a punching bag for Trump
whether or not he's in the race.
It also doesn't help
that his big calling card
was just taking on the woke corporations.
He took on Disney
and then Disney did this.
Disney quietly
took power
from DeSantis, his new board,
before state takeover.
The Trump
allies are having a field day with this
I just saw a tweet from
Roger Stone
basically saying that Disney took,
he says, Ron to zero to the cleaners.
This is actually now
going to become part of an attack line
by Trump against.
It's so interesting
because it was kind of one of the major
things that DeSantis used to
not only get national coverage,
but to kind of stake himself out
as someone
who's like the champion
against the woke left. Right.
And now you see these snarky comments
not only from Roger Stone, but a Trump
super PAC
saying that Ron DeSantis
got out, negotiated by Mickey Mouse.
I mean, they're
they're having fun with this one.
And it's
this is the key in politics, right?
Is when you can turn something
that is a major strength for someone
into a political weakness.
And that,
I think, is
what they're trying to do here.
I think it also shows that
when you go
against a powerful corporation,
then you might not
it might not be as easy of a road
as when you're doing
legislation against kind of helpless
transgender kids
or taking books off
the shelves of schools.
You know,
I think they assume that Disney
was just going to take this.
And that's clearly not the case.
It just shows
that they probably underestimated
what they were up against.
Governor DeSantis underestimated Disney,
and now it's coming back to haunt him
and this Disney.
But what's amazing about this story
is that the Disney move
basically happened in broad daylight
and the DeSantis folks were blindsided.
Now they're calling in big time
lawyers in Washington
and in Tallahassee to help.
But it may very well be too late for
all of that.